I have no idea how to make a funny
introduction for this video so instead
I'm gonna give you a quick slideshow of
cool awesome Slovak stuff go
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today I'm going to talk about the Slavic
languages they may not get as much
attention as the Romance languages and
the Germanic languages but the Slavic
languages are an important family of
languages with 315 million native
speakers and covering over half the area
of Europe that includes Eastern Europe
the Balkans as well as the European part
of Russia and of course the Asian part
of Russia as well Slavic languages are a
branch of the indo-european language
family if we go all the way back to the
beginning that there was a language
called proto-indo-european which is the
language from which all indo-european
language is descended that includes the
Romance languages the Germanic languages
the indo-iranian languages and of course
the Slavic languages as well as others
one language that developed from
proto-indo-european was proto Balto
Slavic that language is the ancestor of
both the Baltic languages and the Slavic
languages but the Slavic language family
broke off from proto Balto Slavic around
1500 to 1010 underwent a two thousand
year period of gradual development but
during that time it remained a single
unified language around 500 CE either
was a language called Protosevich that
would later split and would give birth
to all of the modern Slavic languages of
today proto Slavic was the ancestor of
all Slavic languages the time between
500 CEM 1000 CE was called the common
Slavic period and during this period
proto Slavic began to diverge into
dialects and as Slavic people migrated
over a wider area those differences
increased and by about 1000 CE there
were distinct West Slavic East Slavic
and South Slavic languages those three
languages would later become three
branches of the Slavic language family
and the dialects of those languages
would become the different languages in
each branch the East Slavic languages
include Russian Ukrainian and Belarusian
which is sometimes called white Russian
the south slavic language family
includes serbo-croatian Bulgarian and
Macedonian which are very similar
Slovenian and also the liturgical
language known as old Church Slavonic
Slavonic just means Slavic the West
Slavic languages include polish Czech
Slovak sorbian which is a minority
language in eastern Germany kashubian
which is a minority language in Poland
the Slavic languages are much closer to
each other than the languages of other
indo-european language families that's
because proto Slovaks split into
different languages relatively recently
compared to other language families like
Germanic and romance some people claim
that all Slavic languages are mutually
intelligible to a large degree but
that's not really true but from what I
understand the speaker of any Slavic
language can probably find a way to make
some sort of simple conversation with
the speaker of any other Slavic language
or most other Slavic languages that
doesn't mean they can understand
everything but that means when they're
talking face-to-face maybe they can find
a way to communicate and within each of
those three branches of the language
family there seems to be quite a lot of
mutual intelligibility
for example the East Slavic branch here
are some average figures from native
speaker statements on the internet so
for Russian speakers Belarusian is about
74 percent intelligible in its spoken
form and 85 percent intelligible in its
written form Ukrainian is 50 percent
intelligible in its spoken form and 85
percent intelligible in its written form
but in both cases there are also
transitional dialects for example the
ukrainian is more similar to the russian
dialects in the south of the country
rather than the standard language which
is based on dialects of the north so
speakers of those southern russian
dialects might have an easier time
communicating with someone from ukraine
here's another example from a line
focused viewer named anointed fighter he
says I'm a native Bulgarian speaker I
can understand 80% Serbian and 80%
Russian especially if they are written
Czech Slovak and Slovenian I can get 60%
and from polish only 40% the Bulgarian
and Serbian are both part of the South
Slavic branch so he can understand 80%
of Serbian but he can also understand
80% of Russian even though it's in the
East Slavic
branch Slavik was still a single unified
language in the ninth century when the
first known Slavic writings were written
these writings were written in Old
Church Slavonic Slavonic just means
Slavic remember it was the first Slavic
literary language and it was
standardized by the saints cyril and
methodius
so that they could translate the bible
and other religious works into the
slavic language and they could minister
to the Slavs and convert them to
Christianity at this point there were
Slavic dialects but they were still
relatively close to each other so Old
Church Slavonic was widely understood
Old Church Slavonic went on to become
the language of religious ceremony for
the Eastern Orthodox Church and the
Eastern Catholic Church and it's still
used by many churches today one of the
writing system cyril and methodius used
to write Old Church Slavonic was the
Cyrillic script so the word Cyrillic
comes from the Saints name cyril the
Cyrillic script was adapted from the old
Greek 1cl script with some additional
letters to represent sounds found in Old
Church Slavonic that were not found in
Greek today there are Slavic languages
written in the Cyrillic script and there
are also those written in variations of
the Latin script those written in the
Cyrillic script tend to be for cultures
in which the Eastern Orthodox door each
Stern Catholic Church are dominant those
written in the Latin script tend to be
for cultures in which the Roman Catholic
Church is dominant one of the common
features of Slavic languages aside from
Bulgarian and macedonian is that the
nouns and also pronouns are highly
inflected and have many grammatical
cases grammatical case means that the
noun or the pronoun changes form
depending on its function in the
sentence in English the only example we
have of this is with the pronouns for
example I is the subject form and me is
the object form but nouns can have
multiple forms like this as well if they
have grammatical cases Slavic languages
have up to seven different grammatical
cases let's look at an example for the
Polish word for bottle butl eeka buta
Lukey butl it's a boot l can boot Elcom
boot l say so the word bottle changes
form depending on which case it's being
used I won't go through each one and say
which case it is but you can see that
the form of the noun changes for people
whose native language is not a highly
inflected language with grammatical
cases like that this
can make learning a Slovak language a
challenge you not only have to memorize
those different forms but when you're
speaking you have to constantly be aware
of which form the word should be which
function the word is fulfilling in the
sentence another characteristic of
Slavic languages is that they don't have
articles that means like the or I in
English and again the exception is
Bulgarian and Macedonian for some reason
the lack of grammatical cases and the
presence of articles might make
Bulgarian and Macedonian easier to learn
but the most widely studied Slovak
language is Russian and that's probably
because it's the most widely spoken
there are 150 million native speakers of
Russian and if we include second
language speakers there are 260 million
proficient speakers the second most
widely spoken is polish with around 40
million native speakers the third most
widely spoken is Ukrainian with about 30
million speakers the fourth is
serbo-croatian with about 19 million
speakers and yes I know some people
consider those to be separate languages
but I will leave that topic for a
different video for now the fifth is
check with ten million people and of
course there are numerous other
important Slavic languages too really
there's so much to say about the various
different Slavic languages that I can't
talk about it all in one video but
please stay tuned for future videos in
which I talk about specific Slavic
languages so that brings us to the end
of this video but the question of the
day for Slavic language speakers is can
you communicate with the speakers of
different Slavic languages and if so
which ones is it just the ones in your
language branch like East Slavic or
South Slavic or can you communicate with
the speakers in other branches as well
let us know in the comments down below
and other people you can comment about
whatever you want alright thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you
[Music]
dad
[Music]